[Applause] [Music]
[Applause] [Music]
you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
and this is the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
and your money my name is anthony
o'neill ramsey personality and also
hosted a popular youtube and podcast
show
called the table with your one and only
anthony o'neill
and today i am uh hosting the show uh in
the absence of the great man himself the
legend
uh my mentor and boss man dave ramsey um
and the other personalities who are out
there
impacting the world in dallas texas
uh encouraging and uplifting uh
and inspiring entrepreneurs to become
better and so i'm here taking your phone
calls we're going to be talking about
everything around
life around money around relationships
around
starting a business and so if you want
to give us a call
phone lines are open we have about maybe
one or two lines open right now kelly's
on standby
she's the boss today so she'll let me
know if i can talk to you or not
so give us call triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two
five let kelly know that uh you would
love to
jump on the phone with me and we're
going to talk about your money we're
going to talk about your life
and we're going to talk about how um to
secure the bag
aka how to make money and keep the money
how to pay off your debt you know and
also too you know oftentimes when i'm on
the show we get a lot of relationship
questions and i want to be clear
i want to be clear i am not the
relationship personality
i am not a relationship expert um i
think for me i speak from the area of
being a single man and i believe that
relationships
impact how we deal with money it impacts
how we look at money i remember
growing up some of the reasons why i got
into debt when i really stepped back and
i looked at my
story i was 18 and a half years old 35
000 in debt in america when i look at
what i spent
on that money fifteen thousand dollars
that was credit card debt
ten thousand dollars of that was student
loan debt when i didn't even need
student loans and then another 10
000 of that was on furniture all of that
i would say about
75 of that was to impress
the peers that i had was to impress
the ladies that i was trying to attract
was to impress
the brothers i was trying to attract i
remember
my very first credit card my very first
credit card
was 500 i spent it in a matter of 13
hours
150 in red lobster within a matter of
four
hours of having the credit card hundred
fifty dollars i took a young lady out
the red lobster we had all-you-can-eat
biscuits that was free
all you can eat crab legs all you can
eat
you know whatever you want at red
lobster
and so when a lot of people ask me
anthony why do you talk about
relationships like are you
are you what's wrong because i believe
that relationships especially for young
people
not just young people all people um tend
to impact how we look at money how we
respond to money how we
why we spend the things that we want uh
you may go buy this particular car
because you want to impress the people
that are within your particular circle
you may go
buy this particular purse as we may go
buy this particular bag
just so you can impress the people that
are around you and can i keep it real
with y'all america because it's just me
today
dave and him are out i still as a money
guy
i still have to remind myself
every single day to be a good steward
over your money
and to check my emotions and to check my
personal things that i deal with uh
because every single day when i get the
money i'm like yo
i can go do this i can go do that and
every single day i got to wake up
and tell myself no no
anthony no no you don't need this you
don't you don't need two cars you don't
um you don't need this big old house you
don't you don't need this you don't need
that
um and sometimes i have to gut check
myself and so
that's what we're talking about today
we're just going to keep it real right
here on the ramsay show
uh give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five again the number
here is triple eight eight two five
five uh two two and franklin is with us
in atlanta georgia uh good afternoon
franklin how can we help
good afternoon anthony how are you doing
man i'm doing all right man
you know if dave was here he would you
know say a lot of good stuff but for me
i'm just going to say i'm all right
today man
how can i help you well we are wondering
if it would be unwise to move up in the
house uh kind of appropriate given what
you were just talking about so just
calling in for a gut check
okay okay okay talk to me um you already
own a home right now
yeah we have two homes we've got a
primary residence uh it's about
800 and we owe 320 on it okay
we have a rental property that's about
300 and we owe 100 on it
okay other than that no debts um current
income about 230
shortly about to be 270 to 300. okay
what do you do
i i do events and my wife is in
healthcare
oh nice man you do events i like that
brother we may need to talk offline
because we need to bring events back to
america
okay we have no debt how much money do
you have in your savings account right
now
uh we got three months set aside you
know emergency fund and then we've got
about another 170
and a tactical account okay all right
all right so we've got about three
months
all right sounds good now let me ask you
this question uh because you're making
good money you have no debt you have a
fully funded savings account
uh so it sounds like you're in a healthy
place so let's let's let's
financially you are there uh why
do you want to go up in-house
we've been there for about nine years i
think my wife and i both kind of have an
itch
to move i recently had two children and
we're on a pretty busy street there in
atlanta
okay and it's also a hundred-year-old
house
that lacks some of the uh i mean it's a
nice house but it's you know select some
of the
amenities that you have a newer home
okay all right sounds good
um 800k you owe 300 on it uh so you have
about five
500k in equity when you say you want to
go up in house are we talking about
crossing over to seven figures
for a home uh i'd probably be yeah
right at a million i think is what we're
looking at right at a million all right
cool let me answer this question
do you need it
do we need it no but the other thing is
you know we're gonna have both
homes paid off uh in the next four years
and i think the plan is to move then
anyway
move to where you're wondering away from
georgia new house
no just saying georgia just a nicer
house not on a busy street somewhere in
a neighborhood where the kids can play
okay cool cool cool cool i kind of like
this plan of paying off in four
and would you sell this primary and keep
your rentals so you can go ahead and
take that 800 000
equity and put it towards more than
likely your dream home then
correct okay all right i like that and
break down your dream home for me real
quick is this a
5 000 square foot home 6 000 square foot
home is this
you know pool like what's making this a
home better
a better option for where you currently
are today
uh really the same size um we're just
looking for you know all our bathrooms
are super small you know 100 years ago
closets were super small
um everything about it's just kind of
not
geared towards life and again i think
the bigger thing is a different location
where we can be
in a better school district uh
neighborhood where someone where the
kids can run around and
not worry about getting to run over on
this busy street yeah i love it i love
it
well here's the thing franklin i would
tell you this if i was in your shoes i
would go ahead and hold off
um i will go ahead and pay off my rental
property i would go ahead and pay off
this home then use that equity 800
000 put towards that and then i'll tell
you what i also would do
i would go ahead and just try and pay
cash for the next home put 200
000 with it you're making an income to
get there and then from there man
you have a dream home paid for cash
rental property paid for cash
and you're sitting good so i'm not
saying no don't do it now what i'm
saying is just delay it a little bit
hold off a little bit and then go go
after your dreams
hey y'all this is anthony o'neil right
here on the ramsay show i'm taking your
phone calls triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'll be right back
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special
[Music]
savings
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show here in
america did you all know that our famous
ten dollar sale is almost over
learn how to make faster and real
progress with your money when you check
out our famous ten dollar sale
save up to sixty percent on over 40
best-selling books and budgeting tools
like the one and only
the graduate survival guide and the
total money makeover
plus these make for great gifts shop our
ten dollar sale
at the online store ramsolutions.com
plus check this out we have a huge
gift for you as well you can enter to
win our
ramsey cash giveaway but hurry on up
the giveaway ends at the end of this
month may 31st we're giving away
500 cash every week and a grand prize
wait for it 5 000
oh my goodness uh enter daily for extra
chances to win no purchase necessary
must be 18
or older to win text cash or 33789 to
enter our giveaway
right now and let me say this too
uh because this is this is something
that is very very important the average
college student
will graduate with about 35 000 of
student loan debt
uh fifth of these young people will
graduate with a mortgage payment but
don't even own
real estate so they'll graduate with a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
three hundred thousand dollars
in student loans um and they don't own
anything but a piece of paper
and so one of the best books that i
think you can get
right now during this graduating season
is the graduate survivor got here's why
i love the graduate survival guide
because i think it's one of the best
books out there
we go through the five mistakes you
can't afford to make in college and
these are all the five mistakes that i
made in college okay then on top of that
rachel cruz dave's daughter comes in and
she talks about how she avoided these
five mistakes
so what i love about this book is it's
not a bunch of fluff it's not a bunch of
hey go drink no anthony made these
mistakes here's why and how i made these
mistakes
here's what i learned from these
mistakes and rachel
and i talk about how you can avoid them
and how
rachel avoid them this is a great book
to give to every
high school student who is graduating
um and even if they've already graduated
even if they are a freshman
in in college it's a great book and they
get it for ten dollars right now
you know dave is going but i'm gonna
talk to him when he comes back because i
i i mean that's cheap that that's very
very cheap to give away my book for ten
dollars
and so i'm gonna talk to the boss man uh
and let them know like hey you know we
need we need to end this
real quick because that's a great book
for ten bucks so i want y'all to take
advantage of it
because i promise you um it will bless
the high school student
all you gotta do is text grad i want you
to do this right now text
grad two three three seven eight nine
text
grad g r a d to three three seven eight
nine
and you can get this buck for ten this
book for ten dollars to bless and help
our young people
avoid the student loan uh crap that is
going on right now
we want to set them up to win in the
future we don't want to set them up to
fail
we're not saying that college is bad
we're just saying that graduating
college with student loans
that's not the move that that's not what
we want and so i'm excited about that
ten dollar sale
but let's go out to uh my home city man
oceanside california let's talk to rj
what's going on man how are you this
afternoon i
am doing great anthony how about you man
man i'm doing real good i've
i have not on this show i cannot
remember i won't be
am i correct yeah i have not talked to
anyone from oceanside california you
know i went right there to martin luther
king jr middle school
went to el camino high school for one
semester uh so you know i love it man
camp pendleton home of camp pendleton so
let's go go how can we help
let's go um i just got married to the
love of my life
in the beginning of march and
thank you thank you so much and last
night we sat down to see how much do we
have saved up for a home purchase and
we're at 25 000
okay and our goal is to get to 50. okay
and
i'm just trying to think is that too low
of a goal like we can easily hit that
within a year i'm trying to think if
should we save up for more or less
especially since we're just starting out
our marriage
yeah man that's such a great question
man again congrats on being
married um to the love of your life that
is a huge accomplishment so i want to
take a little bit of time to celebrate
that
um let's let's let's dive in here a
little bit rj
uh because before i could talk to you
about a mortgage
do all have debt with y'all just now
getting married
no she paid off her car loan as my
birthday present to me and we
are debt free and we have a ten thousand
dollar emergency fund okay so we have
a 10k emergency fund already in
california is that three is that three
months that sounds a little low for
three months
uh that is that is about three months
worth i mean
we we didn't move up i mean it's a 15
000
but we already have it saved up okay
cool
cool
cool yeah i would suggest in cali
especially in oceanside
um i would suggest move that up to five
to about five more to fifteen thousand
and then the key thing here is we don't
really have a set
dollar amount we have a set percent
on what you really what we want you to
focus on uh
the goal of course let's just be real is
you put down 100
all right but we're not going to do that
in this situation
the second goal is 20 down
and 20 is so that you can avoid pmi
uh then the bare minimum goal rj is 10
so how much of a house are you trying to
um get into what's your what's your
budget
we were thinking about a 500 000 home in
oceanside
that's what we're going for that's two
bedrooms two baths
and if we needed to get a condo before
we then there did that we were also
thinking about that maybe a 400 or 300.
how old are you two uh i'm 27 and she
turns 30 tomorrow
okay you got your older woman ha ha
let's go
i know i married up and yeah you married
on up brother i like that
very own up i like that i need to take
some notes from you bro um
okay so here here we go so if you're
going for
a a 500 000 home right so if you do the
bare minimum of what
not the bare minimum but if you do the
goal of 20 that's 100 000
all right and so that's
that's 20 now if we take 500 000 and
times that by 10
then yeah you'll be at 50 000 and you
said you can hit that within one year
um i kind of like the fact and i'm not
telling you what
to do i'm just going to give you some
some options if you want to get the home
in oceanside california at a half a meal
um then yeah you can go for that i would
definitely say do the bare minimum of 50
000
and if you can wait two more years save
up another 50 000 go ahead and get the
hundred thousand dollars to buy in your
house
but if i'm young like yourself in my 20s
um and just hitting the 30s with my
spouse i would look into a condo
first just to get our feet wet into the
mortgage world into
you know the ownership world and then as
our income grows because what's your
income right now
uh i'm at 42 000 and she's at 52 000.
okay so you have 52 all right so we're
at 94
000. so 94 000 divided that into 12.
we're looking at about 78 so you're all
probably bringing home about
about 6 200 a month times that by 25
your mortgage is only going to be about
fifteen hundred dollars a month okay
if you look at 25 of your take-home pay
all right and so that's going to be a
little bit less than 500 000
all right so what i'm going to suggest
to you is to look into a condo
maybe get a condo for right around 350.
put down the 50
000 you get into it very smoothly you
are living very comfortably especially
at
a new um in a new season of your life
being married
now here's the next thing i'm gonna tell
you with you all just now getting
married
i would sit for a year i would sit for a
year
shop around write down some goals you
and your wife sit down
and write down what is the ultimate goal
for you all where do y'all want to
eventually
retire at how many kids do you want what
kind of
income do you want to have do you all
want to start a business down the road
i think that you all need to establish a
clear vision for the
for the family and a clear why and then
backtrack yourself there
but as far as in the mortgage man i i'm
sticking with the condo
in the very beginning uh so that way you
are living very comfortably because i
think you're going to need to be right
around 30
350 000 uh to be comfortable
especially within the start of this
marriage man sounds good
sounds good thanks for the advice hey
man thank you so much for calling in
from the beautiful city of oceanside
california man some of the best water
out there
i remember growing up out there man it
was a beautiful
city i almost said something but i don't
want to get in trouble with nashville
but it's such a beautiful city in
oceanside california the weather is
beautiful
nashville weather is
it's nashville hey this is anthony
o'neil right here on the ramsay show
i'm taking your phone calls triple eight
eight two five five two two five would
love to talk to you about your life your
money give us a call we'll be right back
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more
[Music]
[Music]
firsts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neill ramsey personality
and host of the popular
uh podcast and youtube show the table
with anthony o'neil make sure you go
over to youtube and check it out and
type in the name anthony o'neil
and check out some of the latest uh
videos that i have
one of the most recent videos that i
have is uh with one of my good friends
sarah jase roberts the daughter bishop
td jakes and the
ceo and president of woman evolve and
we dive in deep we she actually took
over my show and started asking me some
personal
questions about myself and why i'm
single
and uh and so i answered those questions
honestly so if you want to know those
answers
you don't get it on the ramsay show you
only can get it on my show
but uh with youtube being one of my
largest platforms and talking ben sent
in a question on youtube and ben says
hey anthony how's
how is someone supposed to pay for
college in cash right out of high school
if their parents didn't set up an esa
and for those of you are wondering what
is the esa it's called the educational
savings account um and now
some banks are no longer offering esa's
they're only offering 529
savings account and these are both
college accounts that parents can open
up
to start saving and investing money into
to get some
compound interest to only go towards
college
well ben this is a great question one of
the questions that i am asked
often especially on youtube on my
instagram
and even when i'm out traveling which is
one of the main reasons why i wrote my
book debt free degree
um the step-by-step guide on how to get
into college 100
debt free because a lot of people think
you cannot pay
cash for college but let me be honest
with you ben uh some of the ways i'm
gonna say are not popular they're not
cool
um some of your friends may look at you
weird but
we first got to identify where are we
going and why do we want to go to
college
because not every career field
requires a four-year traditional degree
but i do believe every career field
requires
some form of education okay and so
let's talk about this uh i go to one of
the best barbers right here in this
great state of uh
tennessee uh here in nashville tennessee
he doesn't have a four-year degree but
he
did go to barber school um and his
barber school only cost him maybe about
six grand to get his license
um and the man can cut real good and you
know what he owns
two shops and he's starting to open up a
actual
barber school but it was a six thousand
dollar investment
let's say if you want to be a school
teacher yes you need a four-year
degree but you don't have to go to
uh four years immediately you maybe you
can go to a two-year school
and if you live here in the state of
tennessee which if your grades are right
through tennessee promise you can get it
paid for for free and then you can
transfer to a local
in-state school now let's let's live
right there ben
okay uh local in-state school on average
gonna cost you anywhere between eight
thousand
and ten thousand max eleven thousand
dollars a year
uh for tuition and for books now if you
stay home
if you eat at home um if you uh
transport yourself back and forth to
school from home
that's only about 850 dollars a
month that you would need to come up
with to go to school
for free now if you work part-time let's
say
20 hours minimum 20 to 25 hours a week
making you know bare minimum about 15 to
16 an hour
you can pay cash for school okay
so i think what we really have to do is
start stepping back and looking at all
of our options
so ben the very first thing is you got
to take debt off of the table
that's the very first thing student
loans private loans
credit cards none of that is an option
when we take
debt off of the table then let's look at
okay what do i want to do if i want to
be a schoolteacher if i want to be a
doctor if i want to be a lawyer
then i have to go to school if i want to
be a welder if i want to be a carpenter
if i want to work on acs let me tell
y'all something
i just had my ac looked at i paid this
man
250 for one out
for one hour that's a lot of money
i'm like i i'm in the wrong field how
you made 250
an hour you know just coming here to
tell me i need to add a little bit of
cooling to my ac
so listen there are so many different
routes that you can do but you can go to
trade school
um you can do an apprentice program you
can go to a two-year university
you can go to a four-year university uh
but you gotta step back and look at
all of your options
you can go into the military serve four
years there and take care of your school
you can go get a job
and some programs not some programs but
some jobs like here at ramsey solutions
we offer tuition reimbursement so if you
want to graduate college debt free
you can here's the problem that i see
in america people do not want to put up
the work up front
what they want to do is go to easy route
and then it costs them 20 to 30 years
later
the average person is walking into
school taking our student loans ben
and say you know what i'm gonna get this
job and i'll be able to pay off my
student loans within three years
that's that's that's not factual the
average person is taking them
20 years minimum to pay back their
student loans
on average we're seeing anywhere between
20 and 30 years
so ben uh i would honestly not
uh worry about um you know taking out
student loans i would just step back and
look at all of your options
and see does this particular career
field require
a four-year degree and if it doesn't
there is
absolutely nothing wrong with trade
school
there is absolutely nothing wrong uh
with getting
you know going to a community college
the key thing is
graduate get the education you need 100
debt free russell is with us in houston
houston texas
oh good afternoon russell how can i help
hey anthony thanks for taking my call
and thanks for all you're doing man
you're uh
your your ministry's awesome you and
dave are helping a lot of people out so
i appreciate
it man thank you yeah so i don't
necessarily have too much of a question
it's more just kind of like
looking for encouragement from from you
guys uh
i'm in nursing school um so i'm 37 years
old and i quit a pretty decent paying
job
i'm married for four years and my
amazing life is
uh you know working a cute little tail
off to keep the keep the lights on and
everything and
yeah i'm halfway through my two-year
program uh you know learning during
codewood's definitely a challenge and
you know i just want to i guess get some
words of encouragement for you guys
being halfway through the program and it
being
you know kind of challenging you know
just to make sure that
you know the future is super bright for
for this decision i made
yeah yeah yeah man why did you make this
decision
um a number of reasons we had our
daughter um
about two years ago and i the care that
we received at the hospital was
amazing it really touched my heart and
you know i have a heart for people and
in the job that i was doing i was a
manager of a restaurant and uh
that was like my biggest skill set was
being able to you know to relate to
people and complete strangers and
um you know i know i'm in the right
right position it's just like
man the the incline is just it's it's
it's steep right now with this third and
fourth semester coming up you know
yeah yeah it sounds like you you
experience something at the hospital
that you want to duplicate and do as
well you want to help people
have good experiences when they walk
into the hospital am i correct
yeah and then also you know the the the
opportunities that
the position that the i guess the job
market for nurses
entails uh is pretty epic you know i'd
be able to
we'd be able to move our family if we
wanted to and get work pretty much
anywhere and
and you can work as much as you want and
still get you know and get over time
yeah yeah i love it here's the thing
what i want to recommend
uh to you russell is i want you to spend
some time with you and your wife
and i want y'all to step back you know
put your kids to sleep
cut off social media cut off the phones
and and i say this often
um and i really want you to write down
your why and i want you to ask yourself
why
five times when you when you answer the
first question of why
answer ask that question again well why
do you want that
you see one of the things that keeps me
motivated is not something that really
makes me smile
sometimes it's something that makes me
emotional and cry
you see because i believe if you're why
if our why
doesn't make us cry then the price of
commitment will make us cry
so i would really ask yourself and ask
your wife why are we making the
decisions that we are making
what why why does this impact us so much
why do we want this so much
and when you get that why deep down in
your soul
deep down in your gut you're not going
to really need too much more motivation
because your y is going to push you your
y is going to stretch you
your y is going to give you the energy
that you need when you feel like giving
up
because that why is so deep when you
think about that why it makes you cry
you see america i came into this world
crime and i'ma leave this world smiling
because i'm a leader's world giving
peace joy freedom options
and business and wealth to my kids
that's my why
that's why i do what i do this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neil ramsey personality and
host of
the popular podcast and youtube showed
the table with anthony o'neill want to
encourage you to go over there and check
it on out
i promise you you will be blessed and
you'll enjoy it
but right now we're on the rams show and
i'm taking your phone calls triple eight
eight two five
five two two five and uh chris is with
us
out of dallas texas good afternoon chris
how can i help
hi uh anthony how are you doing man i'm
doing well man thanks so much for
calling in man how can i help
awesome i have a question about
budgeting um and my student loans
uh slash like with a thinking fund for
housing okay a little bit about
uh my story is um background is i'm 26
and my fiance
i'm engaged she's 24. okay um congrats
man
and thank you thank you i appreciate
that um
she's in law school she just finished
her second year she has one more year
left
and i'm currently um a high school
teacher for special education it's my
first year teaching
um so so my monthly my net
income is three thousand four hundred
and ninety eight dollars and then also
unfortunately we do have student loans
uh combined we're about a hundred
thousand and we were doing some
budgeting
and we're trying because we wanna attack
our student loans as fast as we can
but since she's not working right now um
she's making small income but not a lot
i really have maybe around like 200
extra to throw
at the loans each month which is really
not a lot until she gets a job uh next
year
so i kind of wanted some guidance on
that and then also just
um the housing fund because i want to do
a thinking fund so we can stay
in a good part of dallas or not in a
good part but just a safe place
and just to have that money set aside
because i don't know
what the 25 budget on if i'll be able to
stay there
yeah for my yeah yeah yeah
so the good thing is uh you're in dallas
texas are you in dallas or you're in
outskirts of dallas
uh chris i'm in the outskirts i live in
louisville
okay i know it's like where lewisville
is my uh god sister
um ashley is a uh middle school teacher
out there
um and so i know exactly where you are
man
um and the good thing though is the cost
of living is not that expensive in
dallas
so that's a that's a good thing um
okay here's here's what i want to let
let's let's backtrack here
um you have a hundred thousand dollars
in student loans what other kind of debt
do you have
um that's it that's it i did have a
credit card
but i paid that off okay did you cut it
up chris
yes cut it up i did it i went no more
parts of that
okay does your fiance have any credit
cards
no okay all right sounds good when y'all
getting married
uh august 21st august 21st right around
the corner okay cool how y'all paying
for the marriage
for the wedding um we're actually paying
for ourselves we have help from my
parents and hers but primarily we're
paying for it
and then honestly this is a little
praise for but we saved up
about eight thousand within two months
okay now wait now hold on wait wait wait
wait let's let's rewind
uh because we may need to you know we we
may need to you know talk about this
wedding we got eight grand going towards
the wedding we got 100k in debt i mean
talk to him i
don't want to not the dreams but right
we wanted something a little bit more
traditional okay uh in a way
you know we didn't really want to do the
courthouse okay um but i said you know
we can do the best we can
and then let's just maximize uh what
would you do how we wanted something
somewhat you know nice okay i'm mad at
it i mean i i'm i'm not mad at the
average
the average wedding in america right now
is is way more than eight thousand
dollars so i'm not mad at that but let
me ask you this question
how did you all save the eight thousand
dollars how did you make an extra eight
thousand dollars
uh well currently i live at home with my
parents so i pay minimum bills
okay i do help out okay um i was able to
save my so primarily my income
i was throwing just about everything
added except for my monthly expenses
and then also with my tax return and
then the stimulus checks
we just do all that money together i got
you i got you
all right so here here's here's the
thing when you get married you're not
gonna be living at home you're all gonna
be
you know getting your own apartment all
right
and so um here's what i'm going to
recommend chris
is you're going to have to figure out
how to get your income up
a little bit more and not just a little
bit more a lot more uh this may mean
that uh maybe your your fiance may have
to
consider working something when she's
out of out of school for the day how
does she pick up stuff for the weekend
um if you all really want to get out of
debt at your age i want to see
i want to see both of you all well not
both of you all because you about to be
married i want to see you all out of
debt before you turn
29 30 years old i want you debt free by
that time
and so we need to figure out how do we
get some extra income coming in
maybe you drive for uber um when you get
out of school maybe you figure out
something to do i know you're about to
be newly married and i i cannot give you
advice on marriage i i do not want to
give you advice on marriage
uh call back in and talk to dave about
that part but i would definitely say
this
that i want you to really take these
next three years
seriously and you all living way below
your means
um figure out what can you all
do to get an extra two grand
into the house that you can put all
towards your debt
okay that's 24 it's about asking me
about an extra 24
000 uh you know a year
and then if you can do that man y'all
could be debt free within a matter of
i'll say three to four years by the time
you turn 30.
you know and so right now the key thing
is how do we figure out how to live way
below your means
when you all go out man your rent should
be right around twenty percent
because rent is not gonna be that
expensive uh in dallas you
you can find something right around a
thousand max 1200 bucks
uh a month then from there if you don't
have any car notes if you don't have
anything
you all just have your regular monthly
expenses so you should be right at about
about two thousand dollars that you all
are using to spend and to live
so you got like another 1400 bucks that
you can play around with to put on top
of these student loans
i don't want you to focus on trying to
build up a sinking fund to get a house
no
i want you to focus on is put a thousand
dollars in your emergency account
then knock out these student loans then
let's go ahead and build up the savings
account
to our fully three to six months and for
both of you all having good
solid careers man i'm cool with y'all
having three months
bare minimum that's that's cool i need
y'all to stretch to six months
then let's focus on uh building a
sinking fund to go ahead and get a home
but right now i want you to really folk
be gazelle intense
about getting this debt out of the
pocket within the next three years
and to do within three years need to
figure out a way to do thirty three
thousand dollars pretty much
awesome okay and that's not gonna be too
hard with two people
you know it's not gonna be too hard you
guys are young i mean i wish i had
someone talk to me at 26 and
at 24 years old tell me to you know keep
grinding and you have a great career man
i mean
your your school teacher i mean what did
you get your degree in is it in uh
are you in math what's your degree in
actually
my degree was in criminal justice um
and then i kind of switched it up after
i graduated and i went into an
alternative certification program okay
and got my teaching through that
so have you thought about maybe tutoring
on the side maybe tutoring online
um i hadn't thought about it now um i
cuz i kind of really really don't know
what i would
tutor and settle maybe like social
studies that's why i kind of have a
strong suit in
okay hey man i'll go to tutor.com i'm
gonna give you that right now tutor.com
and uh type in your specialty uh telling
me you mean
they'll ask you some good questions uh
and i'm telling you right now you made
some good money i know people making
anywhere from 55 to 110
an hour on tutor.com so if you can
figure out
if you can see if social studies is a
need on tutor.com which i think it will
be
you know if that's your strong point man
why not go ahead and make some money on
the side
using that gift and that skill if you
want to keep your fiance from working so
she can focus
on uh on graduating here in the near
future
but i would definitely recommend looking
up that
and figuring out how can we get an extra
2 grand
in sounds good awesome awesome thank you
anthony i appreciate it thank you chris
appreciate you
you see one of the things america that
we really have to step back
and really look at if you really want
success if you really want to be debt
free
you have to be willing to do the things
that unsuccessful people
are not willing to do and it's not easy
to go out there and get a second job to
get three jobs i remember
watching my my biological mother work
three jobs
uh she'll work her eight to five job in
the school district in the morning
she would get off and go to the
christian bookstore then after that on
the weekend she'll work for target
back in the days not target k-mart
k-mart is no longer around
but she did that because we just needed
that to survive
so hey you want to be successful be
willing to do the things that
unsuccessful people are not willing to
do it and unsuccessful people
are not willing to put in some extra
hours work hard
uh and do the things that they need to
be doing but that's not what we're doing
here in the ramsey show
hey that's a wrap for this hour thank
you all so much this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money my name is anthony
o'neill ramsey personality and host of
the popular youtube and podcast show
the table with anthony o'neil and today
i'm hosting i believe the baddest radio
show in the world
all on my own because dave ramsey and
other personalities are out there
impacting and serving um
some great young entrepreneurs and
helping them build wealth and and expand
their businesses
so and today i want to talk to you about
your life about your money
about uh maybe how to start a business
maybe
how to get the motivation that you need
um
if you want to talk about relationships
what what what are my thoughts on that i
i can give you my thoughts i can't give
you expertise because i am not
married um but i am a single man who
have
uh experienced a lot of things
throughout my single season i don't have
a problem giving you my input but if you
want to talk about money
i could talk about that all day long all
right so give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five kelly is in the booth
uh she will go ahead and pass you
through to me if she approves if not hey
this is kelly's show it's not really my
show i'm just answering the phone calls
that she puts through
uh erica is with us in fresno california
the beautiful state of california good
afternoon erica how can i help hi
anthony thanks for taking my call yeah
no problem at all thank you for calling
in how can i help you
well i'm 33 years old i'm married i
don't have any kids
i don't have a mortgage my husband and i
are renting right now but
we have ninety thousand dollars in
student loan debt combined
we don't have any other debt and i've
had a long life dream to work in
veterinary medicine
there is a school in arizona i have
about eight prerequisites to complete
before i can even apply for the school
but my question is
should we relocate and move to arizona
so i can take the prerequisites for
in-state tuition
and try to pursue that dream there while
in baby step two
or should we stay put in california
where we're renting now
and just try to take uh the prereqs at
local community colleges and just
continue to save money pay off
debt and hopefully cash flow the program
should i move or should i stay put
um erica let's break this down a little
bit
um what's y'all's um household income
right now
95 000 a year 95k a year okay what does
your husband do
uh he works for the county and
after school program so he oversees
multiple schools within the county
okay cool and are you working as well so
is that combined household or is that
majority his income
it is combined i currently work for city
government
specifically the fire department as a
senior administrator
okay um so let's say if we went with the
option
of moving uh because when we look at the
cost of living the cost of living
compared
from california to arizona is cheaper
okay um will we be able to keep the 95
000 if we go to arizona like can you all
find jobs in arizona and keep that same
amount of income
or maybe lose maybe five 10 grand max so
maybe go down to 85
could you do that i believe we could
um i believe that we might
move over with the income maybe 80 85
80 85 all right and we're sitting at 90
000 already in student loan debt and
then you're gonna go over there
and not rack up any more student loan
debt you're thinking about
cash flowing at correct if you did go to
arizona
correct okay and then you'll be sitting
in baby step number two
to do that so let me ask you this
question let's say you get everything
that you need how long would it take you
to get
uh through the program if you did it
from start to finish how long would it
take you
from start taking prerequisites to
completion total of five years
five years okay and how much are you
making a year right now
i'm making roughly about um forty five
thousand a year
and then five nights and in five years
once you complete
what's your income goal i mean what's
the bare minimum you can make
uh in this particular field uh
for arizona specifically i would say
anywhere between
100 to maybe
125 or 130 a year all right
all right all right all right so now we
have some options
okay i'm not going to tell you to not
move to arizona
i am only moving to arizona
if i can have my income around 85 000
bare minimum my housing goes down
cheaper
okay and i can i can cash flow school
by going to community colleges and pay
for it that way
because then now what we've just done is
we've lowered our expenses
um we're not buying a house we're
renting we're living below our means so
you don't have any kids so y'all
literally are renting a one bedroom
you know 800 square foot apartment if
you're gonna go down this route
and so i don't have a problem with you
going to arizona as long as you
use this opportunity to lower your
expenses
while still keeping your income up
higher and you are
really focused over these next five
years now here's my only problem and i'm
gonna be honest with you eric
i have a problem staying in debt for
another five years because that's gonna
put you all at about 38 years old
so this means right around 40 you're
still not investing
okay and so um what i would advise
uh i would advise you to give a call to
ken coleman
and figure out what's the best route for
you on this career path
um i know you said that's a dream is it
a dream because of income
or is this a dream because this is what
you really want to do for the rest of
your life
like if money was not an issue if money
was not a problem would you still want
to do
and go this route with this career yes
or no
100 yes absolutely okay cool
great so uh my advice to you is sit down
talk to your husband
go through those steps hey um let's
start looking for jobs alone we can keep
our jobs before 85 in between 85 and
higher
uh numbers number one will our apartment
costs go down so if we
are in california we're paying two
thousand dollars a month can it go down
to
fifteen hundred dollars a month cool
great if you can answer yes or no great
look at your community colleges how much
is that going to cost you
can you afford to pay cash for that and
not put
any more debt on top of this 90 000
and then from there i am okay with you
all transitioning over to arizona
because you're going to be lowering your
expenses
you're going to keep a high income
you'll be able to cash flow this
experience
and in five years going from 40 000 to
about 100 125 000
that's a good return on your investment
now once you get out of college
erica you know what i'm about to say
right you all need to attack this debt
like crazy
yes yeah absolutely you all need to
get out of this ninety thousand dollars
and i you know i
don't like the effect of you sitting in
it for five years um and so if you all
can figure out a way to cash flow to
college and your husband maybe get an
extra job you maybe get an extra job as
well to start attacking is that a little
bit
because i want you to finish this five
years with no debt
i would love that you know but um man
i'm praying for you i think the arizona
is a good move
because it will save you a little bit of
money and so uh just just stay focused
don't rack up anymore that this is
anthony o'neill right here on the ramsay
show we'll be right back
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back welcome back to the ramsay
show this is anthony o'neil ramsey
personality and host of the popular
youtube show the table with anthony
o'neil
and you guys when it comes to making big
life change like buying a home getting
married having a baby
the last thing on your mind is making
sure you have the right
insurance coverage and trust me i get it
big changes are overwhelming
but what would be even more overwhelming
is to find yourself in a situation where
you
and your family are in the hole because
you weren't covered
if not having the time or energy is
what's keeping you from getting the
right insurance coverage
use one of our endorsed local providers
or eop insurance agents to help
eops are independent agents who find you
the best coverage at the price
free of charge that's absolutely right
an independent agent shops a variety
of insurance options finds you the best
and explains
all the technical lingos so you know
exactly what you're getting
for 100 free
so all you have to do is text the word
insurance to three
three seven eight nine again that is
insurance
two three three seven eight nine to get
connected with an elp
and let a pro help you find the coverage
that fits your life
again that's insurance to 33789
and i promise you as i read this to you
all i was just really thinking and
thinking
at the same time thinking and thinking
thinking about our eops and thanking
them in my head
because i remember i got into a car
accident february
uh 14th valentine's you could tell i'm a
single man because what was i doing
driving
at night home on valentine's
but anyways i got into a car accident on
valentine's day
uh totaled my car and uh was it was it
wasn't a piece of mind
you know because i had you know the
proper emergency funds in place to take
care of everything
and i would never forget uh when they
uh rolled off my car well the insurance
company that i was particularly went
uh went and up they upped my insurance
payment by almost 200
a month and i was like heck no
so i called our indoor social provider
and they found me
check this out america not just an
insurance policy
that was cheaper than the 200 i was
going up no they found me
after i had a car accident they found
someone
and my insurance payment actually
dropped cheaper than my previous
insurance
so what i'm saying is what we're
promoting here it
works i trust our endorsed local
providers
they are absolutely amazing they shop
you
around and they find you the best
deals so getting into a car accident
got me a newer car and saved me some
money because of our eops i believe it
right there
i love what we do make sure you text the
word insurance
to 33789 let us help you
uh save you some money uh josh is with
us in birmingham good afternoon josh how
can i help
hey auntie thanks for taking the call
yeah um so i had a conversation with my
son he's 11
and uh he said he's playing this game at
school called the game of life and so he
told me at dinner that he got a job
one in the game of life as a lawyer
coming out making 85k and i was like
great boom that's awesome man
well he hit me next with the card also
said he had 75 000 in student loans
i about dropped my port so
i was telling him all the reasons why i
wouldn't take that student loan on
because
our family we are doing it as a family
we're in our debt free journal about
halfway through we paid off
almost 140 000 in two years awesome so
they see us
basically what we're doing and how do i
have that conversation to give him his
why he doesn't want to do that
and a second part of this is do i
approach the school the teacher
i'm how do i do that if i at all because
that's something i could do
you know to the second question i kind
of like the fact that the school
actually put student loan debt in it
because it created a conversation with
you and your son
so i'm not opposed to the school saying
hey uh in this game you're you're
you're an attorney you're making 85 000
a year but then you also have this
amount of debt
i think that's very good to bring that
awareness up
but i just hope that the school is also
offering
and educating them on how to avoid
student loans
and so if they're not doing that i would
bring that up to the school josh i'm
like hey
i like this game i like what you all are
doing because it created a good
conversation at the house
we're teaching this because we want to
avoid debt and we want to avoid student
loans
i know you all have to teach you know
student loans and in that option
but are you also giving them other
options are you also educating them on
trade schools community colleges
uh grants and scholarships are you
educating them on how to do this thing
debt-free
and so that way you can challenge the
schools on that on that end
now on your end josh man i i think
you're in a great place
um at 11 years old
your your your son is coming home saying
hey dad this is what's going on
i think now this is where you sit down
with your 11 year old and this may go
over his head but over time um
with continued conversation and as he
grows and mature
he will get it i think you sit down with
your son josh and you tell him exactly
what you and your wife are going through
right now
how you're paying off debt and how debt
has stopped you
all and maybe slowed you off from doing
things as a family
that you may want to do um and i think
you just tell him the truth
and in in a in a way that he can receive
it
so i mean your mom you know we have
about three 200 thousand dollars in debt
a lot of that is student loans
but you know we can't build our dream
home right here in birmingham alabama
you know what son we can't really take
our family on the type of vacation we
really want to do
uh because we have this debt and so if
you can go to school this is why your
grades are
so important if you can get good grades
if
if you can start saving right now when
you're working around the house and when
me and your mom give you money for
doing your stuff around the house if you
can save if you can go to college 100
debt-free you could be further than me
and your mom when you get our age you
can be
living in your dream home when you have
kids you can travel around the world you
can enjoy the life you can be ahead of
your peers
and i think if you start really exposing
him and having that conversation
at a very young age man i think josh
you're setting your son
you're setting all of your kids up to be
successful
down the road but i wouldn't be upset
with the school of exposing them to
student loans
in that way i would only be disappointed
with the schools if they're not
teaching them hey student loans are an
option but let me give you another
option and that is
no student loans and how do you do no
student loans well your grades got to be
on par
you need to be a straight a student
really uh to be honest
um you can look into grants you can look
into scholarships
uh you can make sure that your college
resume is good so those are the type of
things that i would really start having
that conversation
uh right now josh make sense awesome
that makes sense perkins thank you hey
man thank you so much
you know when i really think about this
you know i
on one hand i get a little disappointed
with the school system
but then i'm grateful with the school
system because we all need to read
we need to learn how to read write add
and process information i think that's
very very
very very important and our school
systems i believe are doing the best
that they can do
but isn't it funny that the school
system
and college the main goal of it is to
give us
education so that we can go out there
and get a career aka a job
aka some money to live off of but so
they'll teach us how to get the money
generator but they will not teach us how
to be good
stewards of our money how to properly
use our money
so school teachers thank you so much for
what you have been doing
uh thank you so much for um especially
this last year of adapting and adjusting
uh to covet to this pandemic and jumping
online and teaching our
our young people but i want to challenge
you school teachers
uh to start teaching financial literacy
inside of our schools
our young people needed tremendously if
someone would have told me back then in
them days that
student loans um is one option but hey
you know what going to a community
college is not a bad
option you know what maybe taking a gap
year and working for one year
to save up to where you can go into
school is not a bad option
if someone would have told me that hey
you know what anthony
you know going to welding school is not
bad you know being a welder you can make
80 000
a year after a year if someone would
have told me so many different options
my life probably would have been a
little bit better
and so i want to commend you um
josh for calling in asking that question
to all the parents out there
have the conversation with your kids if
our young people can learn
how to do the latest dance learn the
latest lyrics to the hip-hop songs or to
the country songs
our young people can learn how to save
how to give
and how to live below their mates this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neil ramsey personality
and host of the popular youtube show and
podcast the table with anthony o'neil
going over to
youtube.com forward slash anthony o'neil
and you'll be able to subscribe to the
channel and
uh get some real encouraging stuff but
before we go to chelsea in little rock
i want to encourage you all my show is
it's for all people but i'm really
focused on that millennial that that
young
25 to about maybe max 40 year old
individual because i think those are
those are the ages that
we have a lot of people who focus on the
younger generation right
then we have a lot of people who focus
on the older generation but no one's
really making content that is
relative and relatable to that younger
hip vibrant uh generation and i just
felt compelled just you know hey make
content for people like myself
and so the conversation over there is a
little different you know our
topics are a little different we talk
everything from relationships
uh to um building true wealth not just
having fake rich
i talk about gucci bags i talk about you
know
a lot of different things over there
it's a little different uh but it's
growing massively
already over 250 000 subscribers um we
talk about race issues over there you
know we talk about culture
uh we talk about uh the impact of the
pandemic
and so i want to encourage you next week
we have a
a phenomenal celebrity coming on uh
that's going to change some lives so i
want to encourage you go check it out
subscribe share it with your your your
your kids if you have kids in that age
bracket in the 20s and 30s
and again it's for everyone i don't want
to exclude no one uh but i do want to
make sure that i'm being intentional and
helping out this younger generation
so chelsea is with us in little rock
little rock uh hey chelsea how can we
help
oh my gosh i'm so excited i absolutely
love you anthony you are the best
and i do um watch your show at the table
on youtube faithfully oh that's awesome
chelsea that's awesome thank you so much
for um
for watching hopefully uh you like it
and uh how can i help you today
so today you know because i do listen to
this show a lot now
i read and listen to a lot of content
i am a part of the millennial generation
43
where i want to get into real estate
investing start kind of my own
businesses
things like that and um but i am a big
father of dave ramsey and all of you
guys and so my
biggest question is i have student loan
debt
i do have car loan debt and yeah
just a little bit of credit card debt um
two thousand dollars
uh which i have been paying down
tremendously
but my question is is it wrong
or right to still try to pursue starting
a business
even though i have student loan debt
well how much that story i am divorced
i'm a single mom i was
i'm also amazing four-year-old okay um
but
and i'm a registered nurse but i don't
work on the floor i'm a case manager
so okay cool cool cool great um how much
debt are you totally in right now
chelsea
um so if i were to total up my car loan
that industry wanted together
it's about 95 000.
okay 95 okay so we're gonna round it up
to about a hundred thousand because you
said you have some credit card data
right around two thousand
so we're in about a hundred thousand
dollars worth of debt what's your uh
total take home
uh what are you making a year
so on paper it's 64k
so 64 000. okay was it what is it not on
paper because you said on paper was it
what are you breaking home well you know
the amount that they tell you you make
but then when you include
taxes and 401k and
medical you know the take-home is a
little different
okay cool do you have child support with
inside of that
funny enough not yet um i just uh before
custody this past month which
that was a nice amount i had to pay for
a lawyer so
okay but now what kind of business can
because nursing is real good i mean i
know all about nursing
um you know very well um
and so i know nursing there are some a
lot of great options in that area now
so what do you want to do on the side do
you want to do something
do you want to start a business around
nursing or do you want to do something
totally different
so after being in the medical field for
quite some time
no it's not necessarily in nursing but
um
i started a blog for single moms called
christian kirby cool
and so through that i like to um
kind of help other women promote other
women to
kind of get their stuff together as far
as learning about life insurance because
i found life insurance on the side you
know
um terminalizing students in primary
okay
um and then i just started
my other business closet couture where i
help people
organize their closets virtual styling
things like that to kind of show
themselves like instead of spending more
money on clothes
shop out of your closet when you can't
shop out of your closet if you hadn't
cleaned your closet to see what you have
so
i help with that that's what that
business and then the last thing is the
reason
that god gave me which is to help single
moms get into home ownership
and so it's kind of a real estate
investing
um business that i would like to get
into that i was like wow this is a whole
lot
let me get some advice on what's the
best way
to tackle all these things
and hence why i call it today yeah
so chelsea let me say this i commend you
for being a hard-working
single mother i want to first say this i
i hear it i hear the passion in your
voice
i hear the hunger in your voice one of
the things i i find wrong with
with us millennials and i'm putting us
in there because i want to make sure
that the americans hear me saying i'm a
part of this as well
we tend to have a lot of ideas and we
tend to go after
all of them rather than having a clear
vision with clear priorities
you know one of our one of my good
friends and fellow personalities um
christy wright says we can't really
balance things we really have to set
priorities and focus on one thing at a
time
and so for you i hear three great ideas
with a career
while being a mom um you know i think
for you
i would choose one thing right now
on the side that one is not going to
take any finances from you so that way
you can focus your finances on paying
off your debt
and it can bring in more money now i
like the blog thing because you know
that's just you
putting your thoughts out there but that
virtual styling thing and
going through closets i mean listen we
all know in a respectful way ladies need
some help with their
closets all right i'm i'm gonna turn
this way because kelly's over here
looking at me and all the ladies outside
looking at me so i'm gonna look this way
uh because i i just want to be honest
with you okay so you can make some money
helping ladies get their closets
situated um and looking good
so if i was you if i was you i'm
i'm focusing on my career trying to
figure out how can i make more money
over there
uh the number two is on the side i am
also
focusing on hey how do i focus on this
one business how do i get this to
generate me
another two three grand a month
virtually styling people virtually
helping people get their
closets kind of organized uh so
i would focus really on that
i have no problem with you starting that
business because it will not take away
money
from your debt payoff right now and
babysit number two
it cannot honestly add money to help you
pay off your debt and eventually if you
do it right it could eventually take
over
and you can run that full time and then
adventure off into something else
um real quick before i go to break have
you read christy wright's uh book
business boutique not yet i
i hate i missed her opening for her it
was like a few weeks back
for her and i could have kissed myself
yeah yeah i'm telling you i listen i
listen every week to your channel
i feel you i feel well don't kick
yourself i want you to stay on the line
um i'm uh have kelly give you a copy of
her book
um business boutique you need to read
that it would definitely help you
start off correctly because she's going
to show you how to turn that little
hobby that you enjoy
doing into a money generator then also
chelsea i want you to look into her
academy go to business boutique
on that academy business boutique
conference is coming up this fall
you need to do everything you possibly
can to get there because chris is going
to teach you
how to turn this thing upside down and
really make a lot of money and ladies
and gentlemen
i'm speaking at the conference this year
too and i'm talking about money
so go to ramsolutions.com to get some
more information about that center line
keller will take good care of you this
is the ramsay show and we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neill ramsey personality
and um i have an interesting question
which i thought i
should answer uh rolando from instagram
sent me a damn
saying hey do you guys have a team
toolkit i can teach my youth group
absolutely we sure do it's called the
teen entrepreneur
toolbox kick teen entrepreneur
uh uh toolbox kit and i want to
suggest go to ramsolution.com check it
out i think
one of the best ways we can teach young
people
how to deal with money is we got to
start teaching them that money comes
from work
okay money doesn't grow on trees it
doesn't fall out of sky
and we got to stop parents we got to
stop teaching our kids that if you make
up your bed
uh you're giving the money i don't
believe in the term allowance
i grew up on allowances to where i got
like ten dollars a month
uh for just making up my bed and washing
the dishes well no that that was my
responsibility to contribute to the home
um i think we got to start teaching our
young people go out there and cut
grass if you're 10 years old go out
there and
and you know raise some leaves or or
help you know one of your senior
citizens next door bring in the
groceries
we got to start teaching our young
people that money
comes from work and i also believe that
entrepreneurship
is a great way to do that and so my team
and i sat down
uh we we really created this great
toolbox kit that teach young people how
to be true entrepreneurs
we teach them the elevator pitch we
teach them how to
actually budget how to uh name the
prices
we teach them even how to legally get
their business
started with the state with their
accounting so i definitely want to
encourage you
uh to to get the toolbox kit uh we teach
them everything on how to start a legit
business um at 10 years old at 11 years
old
at 12 years old think about it if your
young person can
can start making an extra 2-3 grand
throughout the summer
what kind of young person are we
developing we're developing a smart
bright young individual that will
understand the value
and the importance of working
pablo is with us in goodyear arizona
good afternoon
pablo how can i help how you doing
anthony
um thanks for taking my call hey um well
the reason i called i'm calling this
because um well
we just started dave ramsey's program uh
through our church
um and we're getting started with their
baby steps
um we done baby step number one so we
got that money set aside
and now we're on step number two um
attacking the death um we do have uh
22 000 just a little over 22 000 in
depth which is
no credit cards it's just our vehicles
okay um
one of them is my wife um which will
probably be able to pay off this month
by the end of this month
which will leave us only eight you know
about 18 500.
um what kind of car is this in 18 000.
what kind of car is that it's a truck
it's a truck what kind of truck
uh chevy silverado okay you'd be big boy
okay silverado all right sounds good
yeah and um we do have a third car that
we purchased for our son
it's paid off um we did have a home
which we sold
when we moved out here to arizona okay
and uh we had we have that money set
aside
um my reason for calling is because um
my plan for this i don't know what would
you recommend
for it um i do want to attack this debt
aggressively
and i do want to fund you know the
emergency fund
with that savings money um and you know
whatever's left maybe
put it towards a a new home down payment
and then from there just start building
up
you know for that to where we need to be
um but i i was just calling a few
what would you recommend uh with your
advice advice on what exactly what do
you what are you experiencing
on on what to do like like um so we use
that
money on you know savings uh from the
our home sale
to pay off this uh final debt or you
know
should i pay i mean should i sell my
truck and just
pay that off or of course
let's talk about this how much um how
much money did you get again from
selling your house
uh well we have a 60 000 uh just a
little over 60 thousand
60 or 50 60 60
okay 60k in the savings right now from
selling your home okay
um what's your annual income right now
what are you all bringing in combined
income
uh i'm the only one that works um so
it's only me
um i started a new job uh about two
months ago
okay and it's uh it fluctuates so um
it's uh anywhere within uh 3 000
uh to maybe uh 3 500
a month take home okay all right
and so we got
22 thousand dollars in debt right now
it's two vehicles
no credit cards no student loans nothing
else we just have two vehicles correct
yeah just two vehicles and like i said
um uh by the end of this month we should
be able to pay off my wife's car so it
should only leave us with about it you
know
about 18 500. okay and that's 60 000
is sitting in your savings account
liquid cash right now while you're
talking to me correct
yes okay cool uh so yeah this is what
i'm going to recommend
um i'm paying off both the vehicles when
i hang up the phone
and um and
here's why you're going to save yourself
save yourself on interest so you're
going to save a lot of money you're
going to be 100 debt free
you're still going to have uh right at
about 38
yeah about 38 000 um in your savings
account from that
i'm thinking in arizona where you need
right now the cost of living there
you should be okay with ten thousand
dollars sitting in your savings account
for emergencies right
so then that's 28k say talk to me what
what you thinking
yeah yes yes uh three three months was
fine uh i was looking towards more like
you know doing six months instead and
that's fine if you want to stretch it at
six months that's cool so you can leave
20 000 in there
and you'll have 18k left in your savings
account now do you plan on living in
arizona for the next five years
yeah okay cool so to here here's here's
the thing
so let's walk through the first three
baby steps first three is a thousand
dollars in the emergency fund
baby set number two is is pay off all
your debt excluding the mortgage so you
all don't have a mortgage
but you have sixty thousand dollars from
your mortgage
we teach in baby step number two you use
all of your income to pay off all of
your debt
excluding your mortgage so yes sixty
thousand dollars you're going to make
some
wire transfers today and you're gonna be
100
debt free then in your case you want
six months of emergency fund which is
great you have a family
you say your income kind of fluctuates
i'm totally fine with that so go on
ahead
and put the six months in there then
from there man
i will go ahead and move over to baby
step number four five six and seven
we do all those at the same time start
investing into your 401ks
and then start saving for your kids
college because you say you have a son
and also start saving for a home you're
going to have eighteen
thousand dollars uh in your savings
account on top of your fully funded
emergency fund
uh you're in a good place healthy and
i'm telling you right now within the
next year
you can be in a beautiful home uh you're
you can start saving for your college
you can be investing
15 um so that's what i'm doing i'm
paying off
that the cars two day no
if ands or buts like as soon as i hang
up
at 250 750 i am calling
um my my uh banks who have
uh the car notes and i'm paying them off
all of them not by the end of the month
by the end of the evening i'm paying
them off
so i'm gonna put you on the spot i'm
gonna put you on the spot in front of 12
million people
are you going to pay off your cars today
that was my plan here no no no no i
didn't say that was your plan i said are
you going to pay off
your cards today that's a yes or no
question yes
yes that's what i'm talking about pablo
that's what i'm talking about
right here 12 million people he just
became debt-free
that's what i'm talking about i love it
right here not with dave not with rachel
not with john
with anthony o'neil that's what i'm
talking about man well congrats pablo
enjoy it man um and i promise you man
it's gonna be worthwhile you're gonna
thank me later you're gonna thank
yourself later
for making the right decisions remember
successful people do
what unsuccessful people are not willing
to do unsuccessful people are not
willing to be uncomfortable and to make
the uncomfortable decision
that was an uncomfortable decision to
take money out of the account pay it all
off
but you know what sooner or later he'll
be right back to where he wants to be
because he set himself up for success
hey you guys that's it for this hour
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money my name is
anthony o'neil host of the popular
youtube
and podcast show the table with anthony
o'neil
and today no one's co-hosting with me
it's all me america it's all
anthony oh neil and so y'all know how i
roll
um as long as you get through kelly i
can have a good time with you i love
talking about money
i love talking about life i love talking
about relationships and i'm not a
relationship coach
let me say this correctly i'm i'm
talking about healthy relationships that
help us hit our goals should we end this
relationship should we
enter into this relationship this could
be a business relationship this could be
a romantic relationship this could be a
financial relationship you you name it
uh but i talk about it all so give us a
call triple eight
eight two five five two two five again
that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five
and jessica's with us in portland good
afternoon jessica how can i help
hi anthony thank you so much for taking
my call nah thank you for uh calling in
you just made my day how can we help
well i had a quick question um so my
husband and i
um just finally paid off all of our debt
so we're looking to buy
our home now but we're kind of having a
disagreement on that
um the average price of a house out here
where i live
is around 500 000. okay um and
i'm looking to put down um a hundred
thousand so the 20 percent um
but my husband wants to put down um
about twenty thousand
so we could purchase the house sooner uh
so i wanted to see what your take is on
that
okay so tell me this why does he want to
purchase it uh
sooner jessica um
i think just because um everyone else is
buying a house right now
and we've been renting for about six
years now so i think he's just ready to
to finally have a house of our own okay
i understand that and uh what's that
what's the big disagreeance it's like
hey
we can't we're i want to put down a
hundred thousand
he wants to put down 20 000 so that way
you all can get into the home
um when will you have the 20 000 to put
down
um so we're expecting we can save the 20
000
um by next year okay um and i think
that's one of the main differences is
that
it's gonna take us probably about three
years to save the hundred thousand
um but that would bring our payments um
to about the 25 take-home pay yeah
um so with the five percent i'm not sure
what what our our monthly mortgage would
be with that
yeah what's your what's y'all's annual
uh income
so um i'm a stay-at-home mom but my
husband's
take-home pay after taxes and everything
is about uh
60 to 65 000. okay so let's just give
you
65 000 all right and so that means
you all are bringing in about 54 hundred
dollars a month
after taxes you probably seen about
let's say 4 500
times that about a 25 we're looking at
about 11.25 for your mortgage payment
um and a 500 000
uh house with 20 down which is gonna be
right around five percent
um your mortgage payment will be higher
than 11.25
um so even even with the 20 i'm still
thinking your mortgage payment is going
to be a little bit higher than
11 25. um and so i think
what you all really need to step back
and
and do together is because i don't wanna
i don't wanna i don't wanna choose a
side i
i don't i don't wanna sit here and say
that you're right he's wrong
um and i don't wanna say that he's right
and you're wrong here's what i do wanna
say
there's three things that we look at
when it comes to purchasing a home
number one is if you can put down 100
that's the ideal candidate
second follow is 20 because that helps
you avoid the pmi
if you can avoid the pmi then yes your
payments will go down dramatically
especially on a half a million
home third which is our worst case
scenario but if hey if it's going to
take you
um if it was to take you all extra three
to four years to buy a home
um then yeah we wouldn't have a problem
with you putting down 10
which is going to be about 50 000 but i
would never recommend you doing anything
less
than 10 so for me i'm saying bare
minimum 10 to 20
is where you all need to land at uh when
it comes to putting down on a home
number two
i would definitely look at okay how much
of a home can we afford
with keeping our mortgage payment 25
below
our net pay what we honestly see
every single month especially with him
being
the only uh provider financially
in the home okay and so
that's what i would recommend i i want
you all to really sit down
one day maybe you know tell the kids uh
take the kids somewhere
and y'all go out on a husband and wife
date y'all go out on a date night
and y'all sit there and just dream
together like what what do we want to do
where are we going in life um and then
once you are really really identified
that then let's talk about okay cool
what kind of house do we want
um is this house going to help us get to
our end goal do we want to build wealth
do we want to pass down legacy to our
kids
uh do we want to be 100 debt free one
day
um do we want to start a business do you
want to change careers one day like
literally have a dream meeting outline
everything and then once you all have
that dream meeting
and you two are on the same page it's
easier
to make better decisions because now all
of the decisions
have to go towards that vision
and so when i hear disagreements within
couples sometimes
it's because you guys don't have a real
clear
vision that both of you all can see so
um when it comes to putting down bare
minimum 10 to 20 percent
i think you all may need to find
something a little bit cheaper than a
half a million dollars
but i think that's just a conversation
that you two got to have
down the road make sense okay yeah that
makes perfect sense thank you
oh thank you so much now you know i
wanna i wanna live right there for this
this next minute before we go to break
because i as i'm learning
you know several of my mentors what i've
what i've seen work
within successful relationships even
when it comes to dave and sharon
um a lot of arguments are avoided
when the husband and wife wife and
husband
and even the family understand the
ultimate
vision and that's something that i'm
working on as a single person that i'm
working okay what's my vision
then when i get married when i find my
wife hey baby what's your vision for
your life
and then let's combine these two
together let's dream together
let's write down our ultimate goals
and when we have a clear vision that's a
clear direction that we're going
and so when something comes up this easy
answer does this get us
closer to our division does this get us
closer to our dreams or does it delay it
does it take us
off the path if it takes us off the path
it's easy no we can't do this but if it
does get us closer then it's an easy
yes and then from that yes we identify
okay
how do we need to do this what's the
best way about going
this way so i'm not a relationship coach
and i don't want to be a relationship
coach
i'm just saying clear vision creates
clear answers
when you have a disagreement hey
i guess i maybe should be the
relationship personality
i'm just playing this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neill and earlier
uh throughout today's uh show
i've been uh talking to people who want
to relocate and according to the united
states census bureau nearly one in ten
people
a relocated last year and that was in
2020 that means
this year there's a good chance you or
someone you know
is planning a big move now let's be real
i know how it feels uh to be one of
those
people uh juggling the unknowns and when
we are relocating but you cannot lose
focus
of one of the most important personal
and financial factors in your move
and that is your housing i recommend
hiring a
quality real estate agent like one of
our endorsed local providers or elps to
help you
find the right home in your city
eops are top performing experts in their
local market and have
years of experience helping folks just
like you and i
make successful moves i was one of those
individuals
last year who sold my house in columbia
tennessee moved to
downtown nashville tennessee um i made
uh
an extra 30 000 and he
saved me eighty thousand dollars in my
move let me say this again
my elp made an extra thirty thousand
dollars on
selling my home extra extra
and saved me a lot of money on the new
home that i purchased downtown so
it's easy to get instantly connected
with an endorsed local provider agent i
want you to go to ramsey
ramseysolutions.com
forward slash agent to talk with a
ramsey trusted agent
about how they can help you with your
relocation again that's
ramsey solutions.com agent
mj is with us in phoenix good afternoon
mj how can i help
hey this was a pleasure thank you
awesome this is my call
ah thank you for calling i yeah i
have a really stupid question this is
the mom question
um i have a son that is 36 years old and
we have two boys and they both have
worked two jobs all their life
a full-time and a part-time job but
anyhow our son
april or 20 20 to 36 year old sold his
place
and you know what happened afterwards um
and so and he sold his place paid all
his debt off which is awesome he said
that's great
and and my dog in houston is from rarely
home so he said just can't vote at our
place because
you know it's not like anybody's very
very often there but anyhow now a year
plus later
poor guy the housing market here instead
of taking a dump after the election
has his might he's not making enough
money for as far as the houses are going
up
and the poor guy i just i if you have
any advice for a kid working really hard
well young man sorry is 36 working
really hard
um two things um how do you keep going
when you have to choose between church
and sleep
you know it's one of those things to
full-time jobs and then also
you know for more than a year or two but
um
he's already done over a year but also
where do you put your money
so that it'll grow fast um
at this point everybody's putting 40 to
50 000 at least over
asking price if you can find a house out
here
so do you have any advice yeah so let's
let's
let's let's backtrack so i can make sure
you have all the right information you
have a 36 year old son
sounds like he's he he was making some
good decisions
sold the house paid off all of his debt
you allowed him to come back home for a
season so he can do these kind of things
but unfortunately due to the housing
market right now
it's been a little difficult for him to
get back out and to purchase another
home correct
okay exactly yeah okay and and basically
the the home prices are outpacing the
money he's making and has
and so at this point the poor guy you
know about once a month i end up at home
and and he's ready to throw the towel in
but not really
don't explain the next day after you've
got some sleep yeah yeah you know but
you can you can do anything for a season
my husband and i both worked in jobs
yeah so you can do anything for a season
and um our dad is almost paid off so he
knows
and we all know that it's possible but
any advice for hanging in there during
this time
and here's here's my question now mj huh
you know i yeah you got a good son
okay uh but yeah but here's yeah
here's my question why does he
how come he still can't move out and get
an apartment
why why do we have to wait to go
purchase a home because at 36
years old working two jobs
no debt mj there's no reason he should
be home he can go rent an apartment
he can go rent a house and he can be
saving
until he is in a position to purchase a
home
exactly exactly yes and the pen and
unfortunately for him when he told his
house of pandemic was just starting
and so anyhow we told him yeah six
months a year that's fine
and we honestly because we don't use our
house very much you know
is is totally fine that he's there
that's not a problem no no no no
totally can be on his own yeah yeah
there's
this is not about it puts you and your
husband
um in a bind this is about your son
is my age okay
with no financial responsibilities
that's scary okay now i can
see if he was home trying to pay off i
still couldn't see that at 36 year old
i'm gonna be honest with you
i think anybody in their 30s unless it's
a medical issue
um or a major life issue no one in their
30s especially a man
should be at home okay so i'm i'm going
to respectfully push back
on you and say mother you need to go
ahead and just let your son know
hey son go get an apartment because what
we want to do is some we want to help
you get ready for your wife your wife
doesn't want to meet you when you at
home living off of us and you working
two jobs like there's no reason
here so let let's get back out there
you've paid off all your debt now go
live your life become the
best man that you possibly can be um and
and take on some ownership for your life
and i get it mj it doesn't put you and
your husband in a bad place i totally
get it you are a great mama
you remind me of my mama my mama will
let me come back home today
and my mama will let me live there until
i'm 50. now my daddy
he ain't allowing it he my pops ain't
going out okay
uh but encouragement for your son is
just to get back out there going ahead
and work
those two jobs keep that momentum going
um going ahead
and um save save
save as much as he can until he is in a
position to purchase a home i get it the
market right now is crazy it's not just
in your area in arizona
that's here in asheville i can live i
just moved into my house
and i can sell my house for fifty
thousand dollars more than what i bought
it for
already and i just moved into it a few
months ago
so the housing market is for the seller
it's not for the buyer
and so i if i'm him at his age right now
um i'm renting um and and i may i may
stop working two or three jobs you know
i may just work one so i can get back
into my local church so i can
have a little bit more of my freedom i
don't have any responsibilities
at this present time i don't have a
family i don't have any kids i don't
have any debt
i just i just need to live and and if he
lives below his means
he'll be all right uh but when it comes
to parking the money
um especially when it comes to
purchasing a home don't worry about
putting your money somewhere to where it
can grow fast
just go ahead and put it into a money
market account or you can park it online
on a online savings account maybe get
like a percent
uh because pre-covet online savings
account was right around two three
percent money market accounts right
around
uh 1.5 uh but now anything is is
a good return on the savings it's like
five
to maybe like point nine percent maybe
one percent
so i'll just put it into a money market
account a savings account
keep stacking in there as much as i
possibly can and then once he is in a
position to where he can go out there
and purchase something
because i think we're going to be seeing
this for about at least another 12 to 18
months
and so if he wants to wait 12 to 18
months to stack up some more money and
then when the housing prices
maybe uh even out and they're not going
way above
the value of the home then he can get
back into it
but mj you have a great heart and listen
to me america i believe a lot of you
mothers out there have a great heart
like my mama
but i do believe men at 36 years old
need to be out on their own and taking
responsibility for their own life
and we can't do that if we're at home
and mom and dad is paying all of our
bills
so that's just my two cents
you know if dave was here
he would agree as you got this is
anthony o'neil right here on the ramsay
show triple eight
eight two five five two two five we got
two more segments coming up right after
this
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neill and blinds.com
blinds.com's 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for 100 free
you get free samples free shipping
shipping and with the new promos they
run each and every single
month you'll save even more use a promo
code ramsay to get the best deal
rules and restrictions do apply so today
questions comes from kylie in california
and she says i am transferring
debt free from community college to a
university
this fall i am 22 years
old and financially independent with no
help
from my parents the college system does
not acknowledge a student to be
financially independent
until the age of 24
which limits how much funding they can
provide
for me i will have to take out a 9 000
loan to cover this year's tuition after
scholarships
what given a low starting salary of my
chosen career i am at
loss for justifying the debt should i go
back to community college and wait until
i'm
24 to transfer well i see
two things here that i want to address
kylie
is the very first thing is you said that
uh you
have to take out a 9 000 loan
okay that's number one that i want to
call out
number two is i want to know what kind
of career you're talking about
because what's a low paying starting
salary for
that particular career okay and
i don't care how much money you make it
doesn't justify
debt okay you can say i'm gonna make a
hundred thousand dollars
out of school it doesn't justify debt
let me give you the prime example
if you listen to our future podcast i
interviewed and met with a a doctor
who's a dentist has almost a
million dollars in student loans but he
makes 300
000 a year there's still we still have a
math problem there
that million dollars in student loans
still not worth it
i don't care how much money you make it
is never worth it
so kylie how do we do this here you got
two options
number one is you can work if you only
have to come up with nine thousand
dollars this means that you only need to
make about 750
a month that's not a lot of money
okay so you can do that working
part-time
that's number one or number two yes you
can transfer
or not transfer go back to community
college continue the education there
until you can transfer over and be
independent
or or let me add a third one in there or
if i was you before i do any of that
i'm gonna go down and i'ma identify
someone in the financial aid office
and i'm gonna ask them for an hour of
their time and i'm just gonna give them
the complete honest
truth about my current situation i'm
gonna let them know that hey
my parents right now are not in a
financial place uh to where they can
help me
i get it that they may make some money
over there but
they're living paycheck to paycheck they
they cannot provide
uh for me so this college experience the
responsibility of this is on me
and i don't have that i'm working part
time i don't have the resources
can i do anything can i um run the
social media for the school
can i you know help out around the
school can i
do something to offset this nine
thousand dollars
more than likely when they really hear
your heart
when they see the passion in your eyes
they will figure out something
and they may not be able to take care of
the full nine thousand dollars you never
know
but i have studied i have seen and i
have
interviewed people um who have honestly
identified someone in the financial aid
office
had the honest conversation with them
and they took five thousand dollars off
of their their um
their tuition uh they covered their
tuition i talk about this in my book
debt free degree
um and how the power of negotiating
and so the very first thing i'm going to
do is i'm going to go up and talk to
some within my financial aid office
and i'm telling hey if if if if
if i don't do this then this is this is
where i'm going to have to go because i
cannot take out student loans because i
do not want to set myself up for failure
but i ain't willing to work
i ain't willing to do whatever i have to
do to get this nine thousand dollars
either completely knocked out
or at least cut down half can y'all
please help me
then number two i'm picking up a
part-time job you know i'm gonna pick up
a part-time job
i'm gonna deliver for uber i'm gonna
drive uber i'm gonna drive for lyft i'm
gonna do something to generate this
this part-time income and if you just
drive for uber on the weekends
uh friday saturdays and sundays you can
make a thousand dollars a month that
goes
there there's your information right
there so we got us we got to get out of
this whole
i can't do it um i got to take out
student loans
listen to me america listen to me kylie
you listen to me too
we have to take debt off of the table
debt can no longer be an option it is
not even
it's not even we can't even see it we
can't even smell it
and if you can't see it if we can't
smell it we can't taste
the the nastiness of it so when we take
it off at the table
we'll look at all those options so
that's what i would recommend
heather is with us and where is he at in
cleveland good afternoon heather
how can i help you hi
greetings from ohio my name is heather
and my question is
is it necessary to have a credit score
and the reason why i'm wondering this
is because my own parents have um
a credit card where they get bonus money
um and they only spend what they have
month by month so essentially they're
never getting into debt
so i'm wondering should i consider
having a credit card or should i just
stick with having a credit
a debit card only
i'm so sorry for the silence i
just find it so funny when people call
into the ramsey show and ask us should
we
have a credit card
you already know what i'm going to say
heather you know i mean
let me give you are you taking a dave
ramsey course right now on high school
oh you are high school you're taking it
right now
yes sir how old are you heather i'm 18.
i just turned 18 about 20 days ago
20 days with happy belated birthday i'm
gonna take it nice on you now cause you
were a teenager
i thought you was a grown woman i was
about to let you have it right here on
the ramsay show but i'm gonna take it
nice on you because i love teenagers
so listen um i don't want to disrespect
your parents because you're still living
in their house and
and i want to honor your parents because
um you know they're your parents and
they've raised an amazing young lady the
fact that you're calling into the show
to ask me this question
let's your parents are doing something
absolutely amazing
um and so i want to respectfully say
this i disagree with your parents and i
disagree with your parents
uh from the standpoint of having a
credit
uh credit card just so i can get some
free miles
just so i can get some reward points
just so i can get some cash back
uh no and here's why heather nearly 80
of people are living paycheck to
paycheck okay
about 90 of the people who have a credit
card carry a balance over
uh the credit card system works for them
it doesn't work for us
and so for me uh i i've done it i
remember being your age at 18 years old
i remember having a credit card
and said i'm gonna use it for
emergencies and never carry a balance
um and go from there and you know what i
carry the balance you know i carry the
balance because i had an emergency come
up because of a beautiful woman
and i want to take it a red lobster okay
and so for me what i'm going to advise
you to do is don't worry about
a credit score i want you to worry about
cash i want you to worry about building
wealth
use your debit card the debit card can
do the exact same thing as credit card
the only thing a debit card cannot do is
put you in debt
okay bottom line okay bottom line and so
i'm not telling you to go back and tell
your parents they're wrong
because i want you to respect your
parents yeah i really want to respect
your parents
but when you as you're learning this
system as you are about to
graduate and go off into college i want
you to
avoid debt i want you to avoid credit
cards
i want you to avoid student loans i want
you to avoid listening to your peers
and you know what as you get older you
may have to respectfully tell your
parents hey
i disagree mom and dad i'm a rock over
here i'm gonna do no debt i'm gonna
i'm a rock with no credit cards i don't
care about airline miles you know why
because i got money
and i could buy my own airplane ticket i
don't need no cash back
because i got cash
i've never sat down with a
multi-millionaire he said yeah i'm rich
because i got airline mouse what the
heck
[Music]
i see why dave goes off sometimes i me
do this show by myself more often james
i see why he'd be random
i love this i love the random show we
got one more segment coming right back
this is anthony o'neil
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
today's scripture and quote comes from
james chapter one verses
two through three and it reads consider
it pure joy
my brothers and sisters whenever you
face trials of many kinds because you
know
that the testing of your faith produces
perseverance
winston churchill once said that
sometimes doing your best
is not good enough sometimes you must do
what is required nathan is with us
in huntsville alabama good afternoon
nathan how can we help you
yes how are you doing anthony man i'm
doing better man now since i'm talking
to you nathan
thanks for calling in bro how can i help
yes
well i'm i have a pretty darn uh you
know
unique situation here so i am trying to
go ahead and save
around thirty thousand dollars in cash
to go ahead and pay for my
third and fourth year or once i transfer
and
i have a job who pays for my tuition
for up to five thousand two hundred and
fifty dollars a year
and make about two dollars and twenty
five cents an hour but
in about june that is about expected to
go up
to fifteen dollars an hour okay and i
was just uh
thinking about i don't wanna write up
any more debt
for even though i don't have any debt in
right now but
i just don't want to graduate death with
that right now so
i was just thinking what's the best way
to go ahead and save right now
yeah so let's let's rewind a little bit
what
what's where are you at right now are
you in juco are you in junior college
are you in high school
i'm in community college right now okay
cool you're in your first or second year
i'm in my second semester so first year
first year second semester and you're
trying to save up thirty thousand
dollars
to prepare to transfer to a four-year
university to finish your ba correct
yes sir okay cool and your job is also
offering you tuition reimbursement
of fifty two hundred dollars a year
which is about ten thousand four hundred
dollars correct
yes it's five thousand two hundred and
fifty dollars a year
okay cool so right now what it sounds
like is it is it a reimbursement or will
they give you that money up front
they just reimburse me okay cool and so
here's the thing
right now man you got to work you got to
work and here's uh something i want you
to write this down i'm going to give you
some
some tools to help you because you need
to get some scholarships
okay um to to get to save about thirty
thousand dollars within the next
year and a half uh making fifteen
dollars an hour i'm gonna be honest
that's gonna it's gonna be a little bit
uh difficult almost impossible um are
you living at home right now
yes with my with my parents okay cool so
if you if you saved
every dime you're looking at about
twenty two thousand dollars
you're still a little short um now are
are you driving do you have access to a
car
yes okay cool great all right so uh
write this down here's the very first
thing i really want you to check out
uh nathan i want you to go to my
scholarly
dot mystally.com and if you have me on
the speaker phone table i'll speak your
phone real quick read your phone
you're still there okay okay okay cool
yeah
um so you can go to my scholarly dot com
okay they are a great scholarship search
tool
and what i want you to do is i want you
to be honest they're going to ask you
some personal
questions they're going to ask you uh
any illness you may have
any illness your family may have uh
what's your race what's your
age um do you have any troubles in this
area and what they're simply doing
is they're asking you all these
uncomfortable questions to qualify you
for all the relationships that you
qualify i mean not relationships
scholarships
that you qualify for and so every monday
they're going to send you an email of
brand new scholarships and scholarships
you have not applied for
so between now and when you transfer to
um
to your four-year university you need to
spend one hour every single day nathan
looking at these grants and scholarships
then if i was you i'm gonna be driving
for uber
every weekend on top of what i'm doing
right now for a career
i'm driving for uber i'm driving for
lyft i'm delivering groceries i'm
delivering food
i'm getting you some extra money and
you're putting it all towards the
savings account
so what i'm telling you to do nathan is
you need to spend one hour every single
day looking up grants and scholarships
go to my scholarly.com
and then there's another book i want you
to go on to amazon to get
and if and if you go to anthony.com you
can get this information over there
as well america this is called the
ultimate scholarship
book and get this year so this is going
to be 2020 to 2021
because we're still in this this
particular year now when we start in
august
it'll be 2021 and 2022. you get those
two materials
website my scholarly.com the book the
ultimate scholarship book
uh you go through those things apply for
every scholarship that you can i'm going
to suggest nathan that you apply for
everything that's a thousand dollars and
less
first then you can go back after the big
ones
but right now your main focus is keep
the grades up to qualify for grants and
scholarships
number two is going ahead and get you an
extra job
make sense yes sir and uh what about if
i go ahead and just wait push this over
like three years since
it like that time that transfers about
maybe two or three years down the road
i mean it's up to you i mean but i think
if you work the steps i just gave you
you can transfer and still graduate
within four years it's gonna be a little
difficult because you gotta work hard
you know uh but i mean i don't really
want you to be comfortable i want you to
be a little uncomfortable
i want you to go in the head and push
yourself so great question
uh you got this and i appreciate you for
calling in man praying for you
uh let's go ahead and go out to where we
at in cincinnati and talk to
karen good afternoon karen how can i
help
hi i am calling because i am in the
process of selling my house we actually
have a contract
already that is waiting for closing okay
and my plan is after that
to go back to renting for a few years
okay i was trying to decide that really
the best way to go
and you know because i'm may very well
be
relocating to a different area so it
would be a
pretty big move cool great so let's walk
through
your financials um how much money do you
make a year karen
about 39 000 okay you made 39k a year
okay are you making any profit off of
the selling of your home
yes how much about 50 000
okay you're making fifty thousand
dollars do you have any debt
um i do have a car loan which i am
definitely gonna be paying off as soon
as i get the profits from the sale of
this house
okay what i want to have student loans
let's just what's the total amount of
the debt real quick
um between the car and the student loans
yeah give me a ballpark probably
about a hundred thousand okay so you got
a hundred thousand dollars all right
cool
uh so yeah i think renting for you is
the best bet all right so
you're going to get that 50 000 and
you're going to put all of that towards
your loans you're not
you're only going to keep a thousand of
that all right you're going to pay off
your student loans you're going to pay
off your car
your car's going to go first you're
going to put the rest of that towards
your student loans
and then from there um i what i want you
to do is i want you to call into the
king coleman show next week because
39 000 in ohio um we need to get you a
little bit more money i want to see you
right around
50 00 55 000 in ohio
and so our career expert ken coleman can
walk you through the process
on how to get your income up so that way
we can get the rest of your debt paid
off quicker
and then we can get you back into a home
but karen
there's nothing wrong with renting
listen i just became a homeowner
four year yeah three three three and a
half years ago
and i've been making my kind of money
for like the last six seven years
but i wanted to do it correctly and i
wanted to do it the right way
so uh karen i i'm i'm telling you right
now and listen to me
as well america there's nothing wrong
with renting we got to stop saying oh
you're
you're paying someone else's mortgage
you are let's just be real you are
but there's nothing wrong with that
because being a homeowner you want to do
it the right way
and you want to do it the comfortable
way you don't want to be
house broke okay you want to get into
the home and have peace
and enjoy your home and not be stressed
out over
your home wow well
today has been absolutely amazing
america y'all have man
this has been amazing i just i just love
this
i'ma tell dave hey dave you know you can
take some more time off
i think america loves me i think james
and kelly loves me
and dave you know hey you're getting
older let this young man take over for a
little bit for you
don't tell him i told him that y'all
don't don't please don't tell them i
said that don't tweet them don't don't
dm
don't do none of that well i want to
thank all producer james child and
associate producer kelly daniel
in america remember the caliber of our
financial future
will be determined by the financial
decisions we made today
now let's be real you made the right one
today by listening to your boy anthony
o'neil
right here on the ramsay show we'll be
[Music]
back
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you